oh look another my club movie review and
I know what you're thinking these hats
hate everything in the Marvel Universe
so why in the [ __ ] would they do another
movie review in one of her films let me
let you in a little secret it's just to
piss your fanboys off
[Music]
[Music]
alright the Deadpool sequel not gay dude
and I saw it last night before we move
on I gave this one mugs up you mugs up
so two mugs up for Deadpool two we'll
get into why we were actually going to
releasing a change my mind today on
Israel has a right to exist change my my
but we didn't do it my producer vetoed
it johnny-boy why was that yeah he said
he thought that there was a strong
chance I could die is it instead we went
we saw Deadpool - I like that you like
that there were some things no not as
good as the original full disclosure I'm
biased here I know like people weren't
thrilled that I didn't like the last
Avengers film these are actually some
comics I have a bunch of that I couldn't
find them about shoeboxes full Deadpool
and Wolverine were my comics it's not
good what I love is when I go through
these by the way you see some of the old
ads look an ad for meteor man this is I
think this is 93 yeah I don't know I
don't know what series it is anyway so I
always loved Deadpool I always loved
Wolverine that being said I acknowledge
that most of the x-men films were
terrible with the exception of first
class x-men - was not bad but x-men 3
was so laughably bad that it was very
hard for me to handle and send Wolverine
Logan was great the other two are
disappointing so it's important to
separate if you're a comic book fan vs.
does this standalone as a film I think
is actually pretty entertaining as a
film less so than the first one there's
a little more inside baseball so if
you're just going to see if only haven't
seen the first one you may not enjoy
this one as much I don't think it's as
good as the first one overall if you are
a fan of the comics of course that adds
another layer and I do think you'll
probably you'll probably enjoy this one
quite a bit so what did you like about
the film what I liked about it was its
already set up some of my life's without
setting up some of the things I didn't
like that but I think overall the
character development I thought was good
they every character still had an arc
that kind of continued and built on from
the obvious one a lot of sequels that's
one thing they they really screw up is
they'd be just that's true watch the
character development in the second one
yeah they just assume you know where
this character is going and doesn't
really go anywhere so I think it was a
good character development overall it
was an original story by the way with an
antihero like dead
a lot of gas how do you continue this
because in the comics you know this is a
guy who there really isn't the same kind
of mark yeah I mean he's just he ends up
being depending on who you ask and
depending on which series was being
written by whom it could be very selfish
character could be very grating for a
general film going audience no that
wasn't the R rating but that was why
some studios had some yeah predation
about the film so I do think that's good
and that's an important point it's hard
to do with the character like this I
think I did that pretty well and I think
it is a comedy first which i think is
yes I think that's one of the things
that distinguishes some of the videos
that some of the movies that I think
worked as of Risa think I think the
approach guardians of the galaxy more as
a comedy than just a superhero films
yeah I think that's why I like those
ones that so much I like or failed
because they try to do the same thing in
just a crappy version of it Thor the the
Ragnarok yeah well I thought my first
two tours were embarrassed there and the
third one wasn't embarrassing to try to
save the previous embarrassing no I
agree with you this is a comedy first
and foremost wrapped in a superhero film
and for me that's that's refreshing and
it's the it's the only thing that works
now at this point the muck in the Marvel
Universe because it to me again I was a
comic-book kid but it takes itself so
damn seriously now as though you're
going to be following this I mean like
it's worn piece you need to know you
need to know everything that's been
going on and if you take yourself
seriously you better be you Logan
yeah exact that are better more darling
well done exactly not not you know in
between squash just that great you're
still watching this you must really love
content or your dad never hugged you
enough or your Boy Scout Master hug you
too much either way if you're still
hanging around might as well make
yourself useful and mash your greasy
basement I'm on the notification bill so
this is the only film it's able to make
fun of how self-important the Marvel
Universe has become and they do that
quite a bit
so III think it works in that aspect but
I thought that also brings you to I
don't know any more pros that brings you
to your main cons a few a few cons and
that nothing nothing critical nothing
super bad but there is a little
entertaining it was entertaining for
sure you can expect that kata number one
I thought there's a little bit a lull
after the first act when you kind of
realize the character the hero is trying
to find himself and he hadn't at the
same time they had established the
villain and what his yeah it was about
15 minutes of like I don't know what I'm
supposed to care about right now because
he doesn't care about anything and I
don't
not really interesting villain because I
don't know what he's doing or what he's
up to or why he's there right it wasn't
and it wasn't done in a way that build
misty I was into the third act with a
disappointing I would say the second act
so cable third act was very predictable
no I'd say the third act as disappoint
because here's a spoiler alert really
quickly just fast or the next I would
say 30 seconds okay and the second act
cable shows up with Josh Brolin 5/7 52
years old used to the gills
he looks good giving a lot of money I II
may not be 52 he could be 48 watch we'll
get sued this will be demonetised
because josh brolin made a call to a
Susan Wojcicki so he showed up and again
spoiler he's the villain in the second
act and it's an interesting villain
anyone who knows cable knows crime and
trap time-traveling component this is
the main spoiler then it changed and
then the villain at the end basically
put it this way the first film remember
when he spells out his name was a dead
bodies was really funny now cuz he's
trying he's getting revenge killing this
guy there's none of that in the third
act it was very sad heart of the first
write the final villain who gets killed
is someone who's almost entirely they
don't really build a villain once once
they develop the character of cable who
were he's not really the villain there's
no one left yeah it's not very
interesting and so it gets a little
disappointing at the end but it's
redeemed by the fact that it's still
very funny all the way through which was
our second criticism was it's not an
incredibly original storyline so if
you're looking for it something that's
totally off-the-wall original I went
back through that's any interval though
no but particularly the trying
time-travel saving a young person before
they do something and you know some
grievous act you know looper back to the
future
same universe x-men Days of Future past
trying to stop mystique from doing
something awful Star Trek the reboot
medivac 3 it's it's very kind of it's
become a movie trope and it's it felt a
little stale and which lend itself to
being very predictable at the end you
kind of knew where it was going yeah I
guess I can kind of understand that's
the whole science fiction thing you know
you can devolve monkeys in that kind of
deal I mean there's so many things that
there's so many films that do it this
film certainly didn't do it the best but
that wasn't really the focus of the film
so ok I think it comes down to this the
focus of film isn't entertaining
yes one thing that they do really well
is they don't try to go so big like The
Avengers film of the Thor films where it
just feels like you're in a video game
lactic scale yeah it was not a fire city
draszt it was not as good as the first
film
it was entertaining it looked good in
funny it was very funny the acting was
good one thing one thing I would say
about the funny I think they would have
benefited from a comedy writer I went
back through I'm to be not a single
writing credit on there has any comedy
writing experience and it showed a
little bit whereas some of these jokes
felt like something you've seen on
Twitter a hundred times yeah there was a
little bit of a crib gag and some other
things that's like I've heard that it's
kind of Dada jokey yes it would have
benefit from somebody who was a little
more experienced and polished with
comedy writing to come up something that
it seemed like it relied a little bit
more on the whole turning to the camera
inside baseball which was again comic
book wise was unique for Deadpool when
when the comic book came out that was
why it resolved this buzz were one dead
pulled became its own series he would
always turn basely to you the reader
instead of the camera I kind of relied
on that a little bit you think it was
too self-aware in this one compared to
the first it's a good question it's a
hard line a tough balance but as writers
that that is a hard line that's kind of
here's something I will say and this is
again standalone film it works I think
you'll enjoy it it's just strong art
let's some stronger than the first one
though I would say yeah I would
certainly as far as everybody's gory but
not as sexual sexual yeah and the latest
al-hadi mouthy anyway for parents who
are wondering I still wouldn't take your
kids to it but that's you know if
something with Deadpool there was so
much buzz when I started out because
Deadpool is this antihero and studios
didn't want to do it Ryan Gosling all
the Ryan's
that being said Reynolds isn't take
himself nearly as seriously as Gosling a
guy from Cornwall Ontario with the fake
Brooklyn accent where'd you pick that
one out Ryan's to medium Chris's oh yes
the first one was this it was an
underdog it wasn't just be created
Ryan Reynolds had to prove it low budget
and they mocked it and they modestly and
they know they mocked it right so they
mocked it and they kind of went after
Marvel and Studios in and that was a big
part of why it was funny well what do
you do when you're the underdog and a
big perform makes the movie work is that
you're mocking that you're taking
advantage of that and now you're the
biggest grossing r-rated film ever I
think next to the passion
domestics I think they even referenced
that in the film what do you do at that
point it's kind of like a boxer who's
been known as the underdog and went and
then all of a sudden you're the champion
and I think there's a little bit of that
in this film where they're kind of
searching for an antagonist and it
doesn't really work you know he's like a
good example of support
not really spoiler but when he makes a
joke about how why don't we have the
budget for other x-men in here it it was
funny in the first one but now you just
know it's a lie because of course
they're gonna toss all budget at this
film more than any other film probably
and they they sunk there's something
there Penny's into it I think one last
thing I think do you think it was too PC
because I I would argue I don't think it
was PC but I think the comedy and
throughout the whole thing was very much
tailored toward that's Twitter social
justice crowd who understand all the
references cuz the reference is only
that crowd would understand what well
like check her Ella true appropriations
dismisses that that being said I think
you could argue its tongue-in-cheek I
think you could but it's shirt even if
it were tongue-in-cheek were sort of
Deadpool's insensitive trying to act as
always politically correct it was done
in a way and that's another thing that's
there's a little bit of edge loss in
this one it was done in a way that
really walked that line really alienate
anybody right which is all not
polarizing which almost made it less
right I mean if anything if someone's
going to say something that should be on
that line right we've talked about this
with comedy but if we're gonna do in the
Marvel Universe if someone's going to be
breaking that wall someone's going to be
going away pass it it should be Deadpool
it it never happens so it's funny it's
entertaining but I would say relatively
safe compared to the compare the first
one yeah but still two mugs up painting
last night certainly better than
Avengers age of what was the last one if
any divorce infinity worse so it was an
Avengers invade in an age of crap age of
crap and then it's just the neverending
the needy crap never-ending night
reality
pedestrian content worse if you like
this video you first off should probably
seek counseling but you should subscribe
or hit the notification bell or watch
one of these videos that's playing what
truth is I don't know what any of that
means anymore
if you try and subscribe at the
notification bell you won't be notified
and if you try to click one of these
videos it's just going to take you to
BuzzFeed boldly fat frauds as they get
carried out of their houses we're late
to break down the north wall and they
get carried out in a land well tarp I
don't know what's happening on YouTube I
know what's happening with mug Club
ladders credit um slash month let me get
to watch The Daily Show one hour every
single day not just clips along with
like 15 other shows for 69 dollars
annually if you're student and or
veteran or military and you get to keep
us here on YouTube for free because
we can irritate them by your support
it's worth it right